Soraya started wrestling when she was 13
years old she became a two-time WWE
Divas Champion the movie fighting with
my family was based on her life but a
neck injury forced her in retirement
back in 2016. well her neck has healed
and she's back in aew
[Applause]
[Music]
it looks like
it goes
aew will be taking over the T-Mobile
Arena on May 28th with their huge double
or nothing pay-per-view and Soraya will
be in the center of all the action and
she joins us now welcome to the show all
right thanks for having me you know what
you said Soraya right and then the
second time you said it wrong okay I
forgive you because here's why the
announcers I panicked
do you want to know the real story I
don't know if it's PG or not but my mum
was tripping on acid at a Slayer concert
in the 80s and she misheard Slayer for
Soraya and that's how I got my name in
the movie they say she'd name me after a
wrestling name that's not true that's
not true it's the acid but we're so
excited that you're back what was that
what was that moment like you walked out
and that crowd went Bonkers what was
that like well yeah the crowd was so
loud and at first you know I was I was
going on to my real name so I'm like
they're never gonna know who I am but
then I use my boyfriend's music and he's
a big rock star right so they hear the
music and then they hear the rumbling
and I I can I'm like they know who I am
and then my name popped up and they were
ballistic and I was like oh my gosh and
I did I just didn't like expect that
reaction from the crowd they went crazy
that night and we're seeing here right
now this is your little uh group you
have here the outcast yeah okay who are
the ladies that's in your group right
here so you got Tony storm one
delivering some punches right there and
then you've got Ruby Soho the one with
green hair yelling in her face they're
my babies I love them so much I'm having
such a great time with them like we're
having fun and that's the main thing and
I make them look very tanned very
welcome ladies well you you return and
The Crowd Goes Wild and now when you
show up the crowd is booing
they will hate using the word hate but
the fans that no they're not fans of you
no they're not they're not and you know
what it makes me feel happy I play a bad
guy yeah the more you boo me the happier
it makes me and it's easier to get
people to hate you than love you that's
for sure so I don't get offended anymore
if they're Booty Mix I'm like you're
supposed to poop you're doing your job
yes I'm doing it right yeah so double or
nothing this is going to be huge when
you guys come back to Las Vegas Memorial
Day Weekend the big double or nothing
Pay-per-view on Wednesday at the MGM we
have Rampage in Dynamite what are you
going to be doing when you're in town
um oh my gosh well there's so much to do
my I've seen my boyfriend's from here so
maybe go see his family a little bit but
mostly I'm just gonna be located I'm
just in La so I'm gonna go back and
forth as well but um yeah I I can't wait
to get in front of the fence I don't
know what I'm going to be doing on the
show
are you wrestling would be teaming up
with Chris Jericho she's coming after
you oh she's she's always trying to come
up to me she's trying to get that little
star power rub you'll get up to that
baby girl you just died there you know
now you so you were you had the neck
injury yeah you're fully recovered you
returned you had a couple wrestling
matches what was that like did it all
come back to you when you got back in
the ring no it did not people are like
this like riding a bike I was like not
to me I was like intimidating because I
got told I'll Never Wrestle ever again
that was it I was done with my wrestling
career done so after five years when I
went to go check it out and my neck was
perfectly fine I was like oh my gosh I
can do this again but no one tells you
how intimidating it is to get back in
the swing of things and then you have to
take bumps where you throw your body on
the ground you have to let somebody like
throw you around and it and the mental
part of it was a little tricky on me so
it took me a while to get my confidence
but my confidence is back now watch out
later the confidence was there when you
return to Ollie's restaurant I can
switch on but inside I'm dying I'm like
oh my gosh yeah I'm literally dying yeah
well people watching right now they
probably recognize you as Paige from the
WWE when you left do they not let you
take the name how does that work so
there's a whole point when you get to
read they're like okay come up with
these names and those two names they
come up with and it was Mara like Mara
Rooney from the go with the Dragon
Tattoo okay Echo and I was like I'm not
gonna be calling Echo that's so
embarrassing but I liked the show
Charmed which is Rose McGowan's pale
with a Butch in just like me and I was
like that's me her name was Paige on the
show I was like I want Paige so he gave
me it but they they copyright it so you
can't take it oh so I like being sarare
that's my real name it's way cooler
names you're so awesome so you hear an
aew and some of your friends Renee Young
from you guys wear clothes in aew yeah
how was that being reunited with some
people that you were with back in WWE oh
man it felt so good again having Renee
there she was a big part of me wanting
to go to aw because she is one of my
favorite people in the world you know
and Moxley her husband and then you know
talking to Jericho and everyone and Tony
not Tony storm Tony Khan my boss
um he was just awesome and he was like
you can you you got the freedom to do
whatever you want just make sure you
come to work every week and I was like
I'll try easy enough yeah easy enough so
we're so excited that you're back in in
wrestling in aew I mean if you guys are
on fire right now when you finish your
matches you do spray paint your opponent
with L even when I'm not in the match I
spray paint on funds too so if you're in
the front row be careful it's an honor
to have you speak the fans want to get
spray painted
wait your turn I love it thank you so
much for joining us and we're excited
aew's double or nothing is happening on
May 28th at T-Mobile Arena